following the may inside xbox live
stream the list of games coming to Xbox
series X has almost doubled here's a
look at every game currently confirmed
for Microsoft's next-generation console
we'll be skipping over games that are
only assumed to release for series X
like Star field and ever wild first up
is the ascent a co-op action RPG set in
a cyberpunk world announced for series X
during the May 20 20 insight xbox live
stream next is Assassin's Creed Valhalla
the latest in ubisoft's history driven
franchise confirmed to release four
series X in holiday 2020 developer die
stated that battlefield 6 is being
designed to target quote new innovation
that will be enabled by next-gen
platforms and will release sometime in
2021 Microsoft revealed bright memory
infinite a fast paced FPS action game
for Xbox series X during the insight
xbox live stream
infinity war told game region that
Activision's plan is to support call of
duty warzone for quote quite some time
and that includes releasing modern
warfare standalone battle royale game on
next gen consoles microsoft confirmed
call of the sea a first-person puzzle
game during the recent livestream we
also saw chorus a space combat shooter
headed to series x in an earnings call
CD Projekt RED confirmed cyberpunk 2077
would be available for series X via
smart delivery if you buy the game for
Xbox one
an enhanced series X version of the game
has been confirmed for later down the
line dirt 5 is yet another game
confirmed for Series X thanks to the
recent live stream in an interview with
WCC F Tech developer Techland said the
dying light too will be a cross
generation title releasing for both Xbox
one and Series X in an earnings report
ea confirmed its upcoming slate of
sports games FIFA 21 Madden NFL 21 and
NHL 21 will all release on Xbox series X
during an earnings call Ubisoft
confirmed gods and monsters a mythical
take on a breath of the wild looking
game would release on next-gen consoles
in February 20 20 th q Nordic announced
that thanks to fan feedback a remake of
2001 s Gothic will be put into
development the remake is scheduled to
release for next-gen consoles
hallo infinite is currently the flagship
title for series X scheduled to launch
with Microsoft's next-gen console at the
game awards 2019 when Microsoft
officially revealed Xbox Series X the
company also announced that hell-blade -
so no a sacrifice will be released on
the console in an interview with edge
the Lord of the Rings Gollum was
confirmed as a next-gen title coming to
series X at some point in the future we
also saw a new trailer for the medium
coming to series X as well the upcoming
co-op shooter outriders is headed to
Xbox series X and holiday 2020 in a blog
post Ubisoft confirmed rainbow succeed
will quote be on new consoles and
support cross-gen matchmaking that's not
the only Rainbow six game on the way
either it's spin-off Rainbow six
quarantine is also releasing on series X
all the games on this list that start
with the letter S were confirmed during
the inside xbox live stream the anime
looking scarlet Nexus blood-filled scorn
and dinosaur hunting second extinction
are all releasing on next-gen that same
stream also revealed that vampire the
masquerade bloodlines - is coming to
series x in an earnings report lei Yue
technology the parent company of
warframe developer Digital Extremes
confirmed that warframe will expand to
next generation consoles another Ubisoft
game watchdogs Legion is also coming to
Xbox series X it's the third entry in
the hacking base franchise on the games
website WRC 9 is confirmed to release on
next-generation consoles as well
bringing a rally game to Xbox Series X
and last but not least the series X
version of Yaka Sulekha Dragon will be
available when the console launches
that's every game currently confirmed
for Xbox series X stay tuned GameSpot
will be sure to update this list as we
get closer to the new consoles release
date